[Music]
warm welcome to the program we begin in
the u.s where it's been revealed that
former trump administration official
john bolton was the target of a
murder-for-hire plot and a member of
iran's revolutionary guard is wanted by
the fbi on charges relating to the
alleged plan
we face a rising threat from
authoritarian regimes who seek to reach
beyond their own borders to commit acts
of repression including inside the
united states
this is an especially appalling example
of the government of iran perpetrating
egregious acts of transnational violence
in violation of u.s laws and our
national sovereignty
well our white house correspondent
kimberly halckett joins us live from
washington dc hi there kimberly good to
see you uh what are the details
well what we know is that the
person that has been charged with these
alleged crimes is still at large in fact
he was charged in abstentions 45 year
old iranian national by the name of
sharam pursafi he is also known by the
alias of mahdi
zai now what we do know is that he
allegedly tried to pay some three
hundred thousand dollars to assassinate
the former national security adviser
under the trump administration john
bolton and that this plot was allegedly
to take place either in washington dc
where we are standing or in the u.s
state of maryland which is just north of
here now this obviously was thwarted but
what we do know is that uh there are now
efforts by u.s officials to try and
detain and arrest this man and to see
him brought to justice now uh we can
tell you that this is not the first time
that the department of justice says that
it has uncovered plots against u.s
officials on u.s soil by the iranians
but certainly this is an egregious one
given the fact that this is such a
high-level u.s government official
and kimberly what's been the reaction
from john bolton himself
well we have heard from john bolton he
issued a statement and he has been
issuing comments uh to national
television stations
what he has been saying is not only is
he grateful to the u.s justice
department for stopping this plot but
also that he believes it underscores
the threat that the united states and
the wider sort of middle east faces as a
result of the instability and
destabilizing activity that iran is
causing in fact he says that
he believes that he is not the only one
that the ayatollahs in tehran are trying
to assassinate so this is the kind of
government that we have in iran that is
a quote from john bolton i can tell you
that that quote is consistent with some
of the testimony that was put forward by
the current secretary of state anthony
blinken back in april before the u.s
congress he said that he had knowledge
of threats by iran against u.s officials
both past and present
so this is significant we should also
tell you that the white house has
reacted to this latest
charges that have been laid against the
45 year old iranian national that did
try to
murder john bolton
what we can tell you is that the
national security adviser currently jake
sullivan has said the biden
administration will not waver to protect
and defend all americans against threats
of violence and terrorism should iran
attack any of our citizens iran will
face severe consequences and just very
quickly this does come at a particularly
precarious time given the fact that this
administration is trying to revive the
2015 agreement to limit iran's nuclear
program in exchange for sanctions relief
in fact the final text of that has been
sent to
following negotiations vienna to both
tehran and washington dc it's not clear
whether or not this is going to sort of
in any way foil those efforts to revive
that 2015 agreement that we should point
out donald trump pulled out of
may of 2018. so
this is certainly an uh
very interesting development and it
certainly could potentially complicate
those matters kimberly how could joining
us with the latest they're live from the
white house kimberly thank you
[Music]